after half a decade of build-up the rise
of Skywalker has finally introduced
Rey's parents one of whom is a familiar
face to fans of prestige television
here's why Ray's mother and the rise of
Skywalker looks so familiar it may just
be a brief flashback moment but Jody
comers appearance as Ray's mom in the
final film in the skywalker saga is a
pretty huge deal for the 26 year-old
Liverpool born actress who's primarily
worked in British TV after getting her
start and theater as a young actress
comer worked a series of odd jobs
including as a checkout girl at
Britain's Tesco chain of supermarkets
before finally booking her first
television gig in a 2008 guest role on
medical soap the Royal today a spin-off
of the popular ITV series the Royal from
there comer went on to appear on shows
like Law & Order UK Vera doctors
casualty and more before booking a plum
role on my mad fat diary in 2013 based
on rate Earl's novel my fat mad teenage
diary the e4 series featured comer as
Chloe the popular pretty childhood best
friend of the show's main character
Rachel played by Sharon Rooney over all
my mad fat diary received critical
acclaim and even several BAFTA
nominations putting comer on a path to
stardom Wow you know the rest from there
comer built up her resume by appearing
on several acclaimed miniseries produced
through BBC including BBC Three's 13
which earned comer a nomination for Best
Actress at the British Academy
Television Awards and Rillington place
some of the series eventually made their
way across the pond to the US where
comers profile is steadily rising comer
was no stranger to historical dramas and
period pieces in 2015 she appeared in an
adaptation of the classic novel Lady
Chatterley's Lover on BBC one but 2017 s
the white princess was the first big
stepping stone in her career a sequel to
BBC & stars miniseries the White Queen
which starred mission Impossibles
Rebecca Ferguson as Elizabeth Woodville
a commoner who marries King Edward the
fourth and becomes Queen the white
princess tells the story of Elizabeth of
York the daughter of Edward and
Woodville who marries Henry Tudor and
eventually mothers Henry the eighth
one of England's bloodiest and most
notorious monarchs both series are based
on books by Philippa Gregory a prominent
historical fiction author pop it for my
mother's own ambition
it was her who creates room for me the
white princess gave comer a chance to
show her considerable range as Elizabeth
ascends somewhat unwillingly to the
throne alongside her new husband who's
considered by most to be a usurper but
even those who have been following Jody
comer for years were unprepared for what
was to come for the vibrant young
actress the most important role of Jody
comers career thus far arrive shortly
after her turn on the white princess in
June 2017 she scored the part of Russian
assassin and verifiable psychopath
villanelle on the BBC series killing Eve
on the show which was created by
fleabags phoebe Waller bridge villanelle
is a fabulous yet frightening contract
killer who develops a fascination with
Sandra Oh's Eve an mi6 agent tracking
her whereabouts as the two powerful
women dance around each other leaving a
bloody trail in their wake the drama and
connection between them only deepens I
think you're going to bleed to this
comber beat up more than 100 other
actresses to win the role of villanelle
and her efforts clearly paid off
handsomely
thanks to her layered terrifying
performance which also requires the use
of numerous accents and languages comer
has skyrocketed to fame earning a spot
on the Hollywood Reporter's list of
rising stars in 2018
just enjoys no heart watch the stream
from his face both komamura know the
latter of whom returned to the small
screen after years on ABC's hit drama
series Grey's Anatomy have won multiple
awards for their work on killing Eve Oh
won a Golden Globe for Best Actress
television series drama in 2018 a SAG
Award in 2019 and multiple Emmy nods as
for comer
she scored the top prize of Outstanding
Lead Actress in a Drama Series at the
2019 Emmy Awards comer herself in the
series as a whole also scored
nominations for the 2020 Golden Globe
Awards which will air on January 5th
2020
of course comer will appear on the third
season of killing Eve there's no release
date yet but so far the show has added
other familiar faces to the cast
including Game of Thrones Jimmy Whelan
and successions Dame Harriet Walter
now that comer has earned enough fame
and acclaim to snag a coveted Star Wars
cameo
there's nowhere she can go but up and
her next role has a pretty high profile
as well in July 20 20 comer will appear
in Sean Levy's free guy alongside a
star-studded cast that includes Ryan
Reynolds Thor Ragnarok director Tycho
Itt and stranger things Joe Keary and
more the film focuses on an NPC
character in a video game guy who must
figure out how to crack the code of the
game before his entire world
as a race not gonna be the good guy I'm
gonna be the great guy okay well enjoy
your lifetime supply of virginity comer
star is clearly on the rise and despite
her tiny role as Ray's mother in the
rise of Skywalker fans of killing Eve
white princess and any of her smaller
roles likely clocked the distinctive
actress right away the role of Ray's
mother was brief but also incredibly
pivotal so in the end it makes sense
that the powers that be at Lucasfilm
would want to cast such a powerful
performer Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker is in theaters now and the
first two seasons of killing Eve are
both currently streaming on Hulu catch
Jody comer on the big screen once more
when free guy hit cinemas on July 3rd
2020 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and at the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]